would you rather is the topic for this
segment let's begin where we have
already begun with jimmy garoppolo and
the san francisco 49ers if you're kyle
shanahan chris would you rather explain
to your team why you got rid of jimmy g
or would you rather explain to anyone
who cares and there will be many who do
why you passed on tom brady oh well okay
so you're just saying with the tom brady
thing we're just saying in general like
nothing's necessary
for the rest of your life having an
answer to jerks like us why didn't you
take tom brady when you could have what
would you rather have yeah that's a
tough one i still think i'd probably go
with explain why i passed on tom brady
if i was kyle shanahan you put me in his
shoes i think that's the route i would
go i think you'd have a harder time you
know hey again like we've talked about
jimmy garoppolo is he's well liked on
the team you know a lot of team
teammates are going to be going i mean
what the hell we went to the super bowl
we were up 20 to 10 with six and a half
minutes left why do we have to do this
you know the brady thing i think you
have more excuses exactly that's why you
have to do it well but
you have more excuses and if you had
brady you would have won the game that's
why you said so you said so i know
you're right it's this is a tough one i
don't even know i was trying i'm going
back and forth on this one i i am but
let me let me give it a try let me give
it a try maybe you'll agree with me i'm
taking a very analytical approach to
this
if if kyle shanahan is at the point
where he even has to explain to his team
that he's moving on from jimmy g for tom
brady that means that kyle has in the
application of his infinite football
wisdom and i'm not being sarcastic the
guy knows what he's doing yes he does he
comes to the conclusion that tom brady
gives us a better chance to win than
jimmy g i have faith in kyle shanahan
you don't i do that he's going to be
able to go into that locker room with 53
guys that he employs and send the
message to them that this is how it's
going to be he doesn't have any control
over us he can't change our mind
their minds can easily be changed
because no matter who the quarterback is
we got to put our paths on we go out
there we're going to play football and
you're going to play with who the
teammates are teammates change every
year that's part of being an adult
professional football player so george
kiddo if you don't like it you'll learn
to like it jeff wilson if you don't like
it who are you anyway get out of here
that's what jimmy garoppolo leaving
would empower kyle shanahan to do well i
think
you're right and and listen i don't want
to be thrown in that corner you just
tried to throw me there i do believe in
my buddy kyle shanahan you know that
corner well i didn't throw you in there
well you're right i did you know it's a
tough one it really doesn't put your
corn you sell self-confidence
self-cornered thyself you can't do that
but yeah it is a tough and you make good
points there you you definitely do so i
hear you from that standpoint and the
one thing that we know from kyle
shanahan about kyle shanahan because we
kind of hear it everywhere we go
wherever he's gone players like him i
mean minus roddy white in atlanta who
just was a bitter guy that got benched
and was out of the league that next year
how dare kyle bench him all right other
than that you can't really find players
who don't love playing for kyle because
he is great in those tough situations
like you're saying there is no nonsense
he is like a belichick where you know
they're just he's not gonna bs you
you're gonna get it you're gonna get it
shot straight at you and whether you
like it or not that's just gonna be the
fact of the matter so he is great that
way uh that is a really tough one um but
yes i'll stand by my answer for now i
still think it would probably be easier
to explain why you got rid of tom brady
to the masses rather than to your team
with jimmy garoppolo at that moment
i'm i'm always in favor of talking to an
audience that i ultimately control yeah
you control the locker room far more
than you control anyone else all right
yeah similar topic if you're tom brady
would you rather try to sell your spouse
giselle boondinshin as chris would say
as everyone else would say on living in
nashville or indianapolis well i i think
nashville is the easier sell and and i
you know again i like indianapolis even
though i was throwing up there all week
last week
yeah apparently it was trying to rid me
uh or rid itself of me but i think i
would it's an easier so i mean
just again and i don't know giselle
neither do you but she is a superstar
and you know arguably the greatest model
of our era here right i mean she's still
raking in the cash you could sell
nashville you know nashville's got a
nickname of nashvegas there's enough
going on it's a growing city there's
plenty of star power there there's some
of the most beautiful neighborhoods i've
ever seen in my life in nashville so i
think that would probably be the easier
sell
nash vegas sounds like a character from
a real las vegas baby
we used to have i don't know we used to
say that back in the day hey uh yeah uh
it never caught on uh because that's the
first time i've ever heard it in my life
indianapolis is a great town i love
indianapolis i hope the scouting combine
never leaves indianapolis but i think
it's going to be easier to sell
giselle on nash vegas right yes
nashville i've never been i've never
been to nashvegas or to nashville
you've never been to nashville i've
heard i i can repeat it if you want me
to i've never been to nashville well i
know you lived there i know it's hard
for you to conceive of the fact that a
place where you actually lived other
people may have never had any reason to
go there i've had no reason to go there
well listen when when you leave
like west virginia then you could start
talking crap about my travels okay but
when you wanna when you stop doing the
show from your your chateau de florio
okay then you can start making fun of me
a little bit but you need to go to
nashville it's a good weekend trip i
think jill would like it a lot too it'd
be a lot of fun yeah yeah those won't be
happening anytime soon this is one of
those moments where i'm very happy to
have a house on a mountain
and uh and and the truck shows up every
day with all the stuff that we don't
have to go out and buy but that's
another topic entirely all right man
you've got a truck delivering you stuff
all day man you're rich
man yeah it's it's really bring up the
rings truck here you go unload your
stuff
expensive things like soap and shampoo
and and uh shaving cream yes we're
really we're really spending high on the
hog here in west virginia all right bill
belichick is going to get the key to the
city of annapolis on saturday would you
rather get a key to the city or get a
street named after you in your hometown
oh that's not even close i want a street
named after me in my hometown screw the
damn key i mean nobody's gonna remember
you even got a freaking key until you
once you walk off the stage and then
what do you do you put it on your mantel
like whoopi freaking do okay yeah a
street name come on hey you make a right
hand on chris sims boulevard make a
right turn on chris sims boulevard you
get up about a quarter mile on chris
sims boulevard and you'll see this house
on the left i mean come on does it get
any better than that you're a staple of
a town forever and ever
why did you go with boulevard of all the
different things i mean sims street
makes so i think it's right it's got a
night it's got alliteration i kind of
like sim street i do too you're right
boulevard i don't know yeah it seems
if it's just sim street nobody's gonna
put it to me it's gonna be big phil's
gonna get the credit for that so the
name christopher or chris needs to be
thrown in there
i i have a slight caveat though cause i
agree with you i would rather have the
street named after me but i would at
least like to have a general idea where
the streets gonna be like if it's the
street that leads to the to the garbage
dump
maybe i'll take the key to the city that
sounds like your street
i want to know where the street is
before i commit to putting my name on
this street right thank you very much by
the way there is a there is a florio
street
somewhere in
one of the towns like near oakland
um
and and back in 1985 or thereabouts one
of the street signs came disconnected
from the pole i don't know how that
happened but it was just laying there on
the ground so i took it home and it's
still it's hanging up in my office wow
uh so i'm confused city of auckland
thief i'm
i'm confessing to the crime 35 years
later i believe all statutes and statues
of limitation have expired i did steal a
street sign that says florio street i
would have done the same somewhere
somewhere between oakland like south of
oakland or in oakland or berkeley or
somewhere around there one of those
towns but uh when we were out there for
the super bowl a few years ago
i was tempted to go steal the another
one oh steal the new one yeah were you
gonna bring your screwdriver this time
and unscrew it and then take it home or
just hope it would fall off again listen
let me just say this since we're going
down this this street i can't quite
remember how we got the thing off there
may have been alcohol involved that
night which spurred the inside
project all together i do have this
vague recollection of one of my friends
hanging from the top of the thing
banging on it with something and
eventually it came off oh damn so this
wasn't just this was vandalism and thief
city of focus all sorts let me know what
you want me to bring this guy in town
i'll bring him in you have no
jurisdiction over me oakland
all right uh if you're nick foles would
you rather bet on yourself in a
quarterback competition with gardner
minshew or roll the dice and welcome a
trade to an unknown destination
wow
i i think that i would probably go roll
the dice and welcome a trade to an
unknown destination i just feel like in
jacksonville gardner minshew has
won over the city and the organization
both double whammy and i think that's
hard to overcome if you're a guy like
nick foles um yeah for yeah right now i
would i would this is a tough one it
really is but i i think i would rather
roll the dice welcome a trade yeah it's
an unknown destination but you know you
also might get a shot here to be a
starter somebody signed you as a true
starter here and you don't even have to
battle it out with anybody
yeah um i i agree with you and and look
they they clearly want minshu i don't
know what kind of a competition it's
going to be i think one of the reasons
that they kept doug maron as the coach
dave caldwell's the gm they brought in
minshu and minshu is the guy they can
build around because look remember even
though they're only playing six regular
season home games in jacksonville this
year more guys are going to show up and
more gals are going to show up more fans
more money more everything to see
gardner minshew play period he's the guy
that has galvanized that fan base and
that's the guy they want playing
quarterback and they want to see what
his ceiling is yeah right what is his
ceiling we don't know we just started to
scratch the surface maybe or maybe he's
already out of ceiling there's only one
way to find out all right uh one more
real quick if you're derek henry would
you rather sign one
big contract to be a bell cow running
back or take less on a team that has
multiple running backs it will extend
your career necessarily deeper and
deeper than if you go out and run the
ball 30 times a game yeah i know but you
know like i'm gonna go with the first
one there sign one big contract to be a
bell cow like you know the second one
okay there's too many moving parts first
off like how much less are we talking
about right and then the other thing i
would say too is like running backs by
committee sound cool until the head
coach watches the guy derek henry run
the ball and starts to go hey screw the
rest of the committee let's keep giving
him the ball he keeps getting seven
yards of carry and man i'm out here on
the field offensive coordinator while
you're up in the box and man it's just
they don't even want to tackle them so i
don't know necessarily you would get
what you want in the you know multiple
running backs type of uh situation there
i think ultimately he'd become the bell
cow once again too there
i know we're doing a hypotheticals here
but yes i would rather just sign the big
contract get your money and go from
there
and i i really do feel like the titans
didn't draft him with the eye that he
would become a bell cow that they wanted
to have multiple running backs remember
they had demarco murray yeah but when
the guy's that good you know that and
that's the thing you can go in to a
season or a game or or whatever
expecting to use multiple running backs
but when one guy is unstoppable
uh
it's harder to take him off mike and he
doesn't seem like a running back that
you can just give the ball 10 times a
game right one thing we see as seasons
go on as games get longer he's better so
to have him split up the carries and
stuff like that i think takes away from
what you're really paying for in derek
henry
that's one of the lost realities of the
nfl as we get away from the bell cow
running back you know it hurts so much
to get hit by the guy early you have
worn them down psychologically by the
fourth right and they no longer want to
take the punishment and all of a sudden
you're busting these long runs that you
wouldn't bust if you're only getting
those 10 carries again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports